[Music]
hello everyone I'm Jim Vidal welcome to
the strategic class if you came to see
another class then I don't know what to
tell you
so today I wanted to go over this game I
play it in Chicago from earlier this
year for some reason I've been going
over my games in this class and other
classes I've been going over other games
I didn't actually plan it this way but
for some reason for this class I like to
show whole game since I can kind of give
you my perspective from not just looking
over the game afterwards like I would if
it was someone else's game but I can
tell you what I was thinking during the
game and how I made decisions so it kind
of is a different vibe than going over
someone else's game also because it's me
playing I make lots of mistakes and you
guys can correct my moves and stuff
which is also fun so anyway I'm black
I'm kind of I don't want to say it's a
must-win game I think it was fifth round
or something maybe sixth round but it
was a game where if I don't win this
game let's just say I'd be sad because I
was already behind in the tournament I
lost in round two I was already kind of
chasing the leading pack but basically
I'm black against an opponent who you
know a couple hundred points low-rated
than me solid player but someone I
should be beating so it's basically I
don't want to say a must-win game
because that's a little much but you
know a full point would be a lot better
than a half plan so I'm giving you that
perspective because it really kind of
comes into play later so my opponent
always opens e4 we play a Lopez I've
been experimenting with you know the
Steines deferred lately just kind of a I
don't know
sort of a classic opening but I like to
play classic openings that aren't as
popular of course now everyone's playing
it so it's kind of annoying but the idea
of the deferred throwing in a six by the
way does anyone know why they do this
just to wake you up
let's go into that so d4 is actually not
such a bad move but it does give black a
nice option here if the bishop were here
and you played a six black white could
simply take the knight right now the
Bishop's committed to this square so
which option do I have for black here
mm-hmm so Bishop goes back Knight takes
pawn now I think black boy can play c3
or a move like that and get some
compensation for the pond and it's not
so bad for for white but there's a nice
little trick if Queen takes d4 like I
actually showed this in a previous
lecture so you guys might be familiar
but the idea is you play c5 Queen d5 it
looks like it's a draw right there
should be six check but now you do not
play Bishop e6 unless you want to
torment white by repeating twice what do
you do yes Brooks defended bishops traps
Life is Beautiful my opponent
unfortunately decided not to do this
he castled I played Bishop d7 c3 this is
very typical I don't to focus on the
opening too much g7 this is kind of what
people are doing now it used to be
people would play moves like Knight f6
and 97 but this is an attempt to be
slightly more active you're gonna laugh
at that claim when you see what happened
later h3 which is actually a tricky move
preventing my Bishop from going to g4
later just kind of a nice housekeeping
move I use the word housekeeping moved
just it improves your position in small
ways like you keep the bishop out you
give your king lift just kind of a nice
little move and in some positions
housekeeping moves are kind of nice
because you don't have much to do so you
just improve slightly I'm out of six
rook e1 castles
maybe two so there are lots of different
ways to play
I chose rookie Yates so rookie eight
looks like just a normal developing move
but I would say this actually is a
preventative move also what is rookie
eight prevent exactly why would like to
maneuver the knight to g3 and I've
always asked this because a lot of
people kind of do this take this for
granted when they play the Royal Oh PES
they're like okay my knight mudra mr. g3
why are you going here there's a pawn
here restricting your knight why are you
wasting time bringing your knight here
but there is a good reason exactly this
bishop now is stuck this queen is also
blocked the knight here is not amazing
but it's out of the way but you will
find that often later in the game you
have to move this Knight again because
it's just hitting this pawn it's not
really that good but in this case white
would like to be able to get this
picture out but the problem now is I can
simply take this pawn and then this guy
hangs so rook e8 looks like a developing
move but it also has a direct purpose
which is it prevents Knight bet so white
of course wants to prevent this with
Bishop c2 so white black can try ideas
like taking a night before but I didn't
think they really led anywhere and of
course you always have to be careful of
allowing the big palm center so I played
Queen e7 this idea is not bad but I
would say it's extremely slow My dear
though is simply to connect my rooks and
now there is always the idea of maybe
playing Bishop h6 why would Bishop h6 be
a move I want to play I have a fee and
shedder a bishop what am I doing with
Bishop h6 yeah I mean like the idea is
that eventually white might try to play
d5 or white might try to do something
and ideas my rooks are kind of connected
and if I play Bishop h6 I can at least
trade off some pieces I'm the one who's
cracked right that's the mean mhm
not just to develop the Queen but to
give myself room right now I don't have
any room I'm just like you know in a
closet right I need to be able to get
some room so my pieces can kind of get
out and it's one of the drawbacks to
openings like this you have to be
willing to play with less space and part
of that means you got a trade usually if
you don't trade anything your pieces
just roam around on the first rank which
is never fun unless you're into that
sort of thing so white played Knight g3
if I try Bishop h6 now I have to watch
out for moves like Knight g5 and also
there's ideas of taking and then this
Bishop can hang occasionally I have to
be a little careful
so instead and this is actually a funny
moment because I know there's a game I
was following here played by Andre Caen
who's a very strong gym and he played
rook a d8 but I was thinking here and
I'm like man rook a d8 then Bishop g5 I
have to worry about this pin I don't to
play h6 because then my bishop has to
move so I'm like I can do better than
I'm Dracon and this is always a
dangerous line of thinking when you try
to vary from your preparation but I
played a kind of an interesting move I
played King h8 but you guys are gonna
laugh at me so hard when you see my idea
so white played Bishop g5 which is a
fairly logical move what was my plan
you're half right now I remember how I
said Bishop g7 was the active line you
guys can feel free to laugh now there's
nothing too active about this but my
goal is just to play very very simply in
that if the position stays closed
maneuvers like this are not such a big
deal right because there's nothing
happening I can take my time I can
maneuver my pieces but the main idea is
I was stuck I didn't have anything to do
in the center so I'm trying to fix my
pieces if given time like say white
plays I don't know rook c1 or something
like this my general plan is to play f6
Bishop h6 maybe trade the bishops Queen
out Knight comes out I'm kind of holding
on nothing is pretty if you ask the
computer the computer is like man your
positions ugly but it also doesn't come
up with anything that convincing so it's
all kind of possible I also don't have
to trade right away I could play a move
like this one thing I will say though is
that I would be very careful playing
moves like this a lot of people they
play the Lopez and they see f5 and their
eyes light up they're like oh Christmas
I'm gonna start attacking you have to be
very careful with moves like this anyone
can tell me why
this is all possible you can even just
open up the board keep in mind I cannot
take with the palm so if I have to take
with the night this is already kind of
ugly right I have split pawns a kink
weak King but let's try your move which
I also think is very promising
9h vines also there are lots of decent
moves here I think that h5 maybe I can
try e4
but even this quite honestly is very
dangerous like you see how you're
launching your puns so you kind of feel
good about yourself but you will feel
very bad if your king ends up getting
stripped naked and just running around
it's not gonna be fun so you have to be
very very careful about moves like f5 I
would say that most players when they
start out playing these kind of
positions they rush too much let's face
it and I'm not gonna blame you because I
was the one who played this way you
played Queen e7 Queen f8 and I g8
do you really want to take the
initiative now you don't quite deserve
the initiative quite yet and I'm again
I'm talking to myself it happens all the
time
but my good idea at least in the game
was to not do that but to play f6
maneuver my net around play Bishop here
and try to just do something with my
life because honestly in this position I
just was not sure what to do this is not
a lot I can do that's acted but my
opponent took on e5 now this in some
ways this capture makes sense because
when your opponent withdraws from the
center that's usually the moment to play
in the center he doesn't want to close
the position so opening the positions
kind of logical but it also does
something for me which is very
convenient what do you think that would
be it opens the bishop that's very true
well like so I take with the knight so
what have I done probably he should take
right
what is he doing how is he helping me
he's exchanging my pieces exactly he's
not taking advantage of my extra space
and I can tell you and I don't know if
this was his original intention or not
but in this position he lets an instinct
take over which a lot of people this
happens if you were playing a lower
rated opponent I doubt he would play
this way he would probably just build
this position normally which would be
better but when people play higher rated
opponents oftentimes whether they're
aggressive players or not
they often try to trade too much they
think okay if I trade off the pieces my
opponent wants to beat me this is gonna
make later life harder and that's kind
of what he did he took the pieces off f4
is a little risky with the bishop here
so he went back which I don't have a
problem with so I put improve my bishop
makes sense right Bishop t4 which I
don't think by itself is such a bad move
rookie seven but here I think he took
completely the wrong approach to the
position well seven yes so it's White's
move my idea by the way I've rook here
is I'm just gonna double very simple
right what would you do his way I'm not
sure the Queen does a whole lot on g4 it
might get hit by the knight also it's
nice to bring the Queen where you want
to play but you have to make sure the
Queen does something in particular
sometimes it can just get hit you know I
don't know if I were white I'd probably
just go here maybe rook do you want next
ask yourself dude your nights on g8 what
are you doing if takes then pawn takes
hmm h4 is possible but you have to be
careful if you play h4 I might play
Knight back to have six and then you you
can weaken yourself with moves like h4
sometimes you have to be careful but
honestly I would just bring my pieces
through the center and ask black what
are you doing I'm not saying my position
is so bad but it's a little bit passive
this whole night g8 idea was a little
too fanciful by me and I know you're
probably thinking like this is what you
dream about putting your energy
but it's trying for too much in any case
he helped me out
I played Bishop takes Bishop why is this
bad
exactly now if he lets me if he lets me
take it's a different story because he
plays pawn takes why is that so
different he has the center and he's a
better pawn structure even if he just
plays d5 at some point I have a weakness
here which is a really this pawn
structure by the way just to show you
guys takes I'm gonna play just random
moves kind of this pawn structure is
often a nightmare for black because this
pawn is very defensible right whereas
this pawn blot white just triples on the
C file and basically black spends the
rest of his miserable life guarding this
pawn if you ever push it and takes you
ruin your pawn structure often you have
to so I'm not saying this particular
position in particular is that horrible
but in general if you're black in e5
structures avoid this pawn structure
like the plague if your pawn is here you
have almost a Benoni
which is a totally different opening
it's the d4 opening that's completely
different but if your pawn is here do
not get this pawn structure avoid just
letting you know I'm just saving you
hours of suffering because I have
suffered for many an hour with that pawn
structure so luckily he took and played
Queen d4 so you can guess what mode he's
in now trade the pieces let this guy try
to beat me he's the GM I don't have to
do anything but I was actually very
happy to see this because my position
and it doesn't matter what the situation
is honestly if you told me it's like a
must-win game you if you win you get
thousands of dollars if you draw you get
nothing I would still be happy to see
this can you tell me why that would be
and I would say the reverse is also true
if I were white and someone told me if
you draw you get thousands of dollars
winning is no different if you lose you
get nothing I still would not play this
way I would play Queen d2 so why is
simplifying so bad
exactly you're just throwing away the
quality of your position that makes it
good in this position if you trade off a
lot of pieces I have a potential
weakness on e4 I have no weaknesses
I have rooks on doubled what could be
wrong with my position what I say blacks
better not really it should still be a
draw but then you're not playing for
anything black I can play this out
forever I never have to give him a draw
there are no rules like this not to my
knowledge anyway I can just play this
out I can try to probe him which is kind
of what happened I can try to see if he
makes some errors if he played Queen d2
keeping the Queen's on he keeps up the
pressure so basically I mean it doesn't
matter who your opponent is you could be
playing Magnus Carlsen you want to play
Queen d2 put him under pressure make it
so that they have to first equalize in
order to beat you right they don't just
go from being much worse or being worse
to just winning right so make them
equalize before they try to get an
advantage so this is and I mentioned
this just because it's a type of
thinking that is so common that happens
all the time and it's a type of thinking
if you couldn't avoid it it's so much
better so I was black so I played rook a
Yeats of course I don't want to take and
give him the better palm structure right
so he plays rook e3
so now what I have to improve my
position how do i improve my position
yeah fix my stupid night making mistakes
is all well and good but if you're not
willing to then fix them you're gonna
have an even tougher time again 98 when
I played it I had a specific purpose it
doesn't make it a good move but quite
often when you put your net on g8 you
don't plan to leave it there you want to
improve it so I could try I was even
vaguely considering moves like h5 but I
think these moves are really bad because
then if white just moves and doesn't
trade wait a second why do I have a why
do I have why did I create a weakness
over here what was the purpose of this
so when in doubt just improve your worst
piece this is a trick there's an author
you guys probably heard of him Jacob a
guard he does lots of good chess books
I'd recommend them one of his things is
that one of the questions you should ask
yourself in any position is what your
worst pieces and if you're not sure what
to do in a position improve your worst
piece very rarely is it a bad choice and
again he has more specific rules again
some of them I follow someone whom I
don't but I use it especially when I'm
stuck if I'm stuck and I don't know what
to do I ask them myself what piece of
mind is bad oh I'll fix this guy and
it's just the likelihood of Knight f6
being a bad move is almost zero just
there's no way fixing a piece is gonna
be bad so he plays here so I maneuver
around and he decides to trade I'm of
course happy to let him trade not just
because I don't want to take to the pawn
structure but also when he takes what
happens exactly believe it or not one of
the next moves I was thinking about was
even removed like King g8 just to
improve my King so I was very happy that
he took but it's still pretty much equal
right nothing much is happening how am I
gonna beat this guy well he fixes his
knight he realizes his knight needs some
fixing
so here you have a position like this
right I technically have one weakness
and only one weakness to work with what
is that efore right this space advantage
I would say is only meaningful if you're
actually run out of space when there
were all the pieces on the board this is
base advantage is really annoying right
now that it's an endgame all my pieces
have good squares I don't mind and it's
one of the reasons why I don't think
blacks objectively better but if you
were to force me to pick a side I would
probably pick back because I'm the only
one it was something to play for here
and again it's white do not put yourself
in these situations if you don't have to
but I kind of digress again what do I do
like how do you how do you work this
because really it's only one weakness
one weakness is very rarely enough to
win a chess game unless that's a really
bad one and this is definitely not a bad
one if given a chance why I can even
play a move like f3 so what do I have to
do how can I try to do something
possibly but he wants to improve his
night anyway right
so I play a five I don't want to say
this is some star move it's just a move
I'm just giving myself a little extra
queenside space right putting my pawns
at dark squares I have a bishop on light
squares so I want my pawns on dark right
that's the usual rule but also it kind
of forces him to think because it gives
me options
first of all does white want to play a4
or not what do you guys think no why
does might not want to play a 495 and
even if you can play b3 at some point
there but I mean I understand now it
drops a pawn maybe although there's f3
you have to be careful about taking this
fun because you are pinned but the point
is more that I don't care if I can win a
pawn by force
a4 puts another pawn on light squares
and this is one of the strategic
concepts when you have any kind of
Bishop endgame often it's a battle to
force your opponent's pawns on the same
colors their Bishop that's your main
goal if you can do that then it often
means that they have to just play with
kind of an ugly piece it's not again
it's not always enough to win but I'm
not trying you have to realize I'm
actually trying to win this game
that sounds misleading of course trying
to win this game I'm just trying to do a
little bit at a time I want him to make
one concession then maybe it'll make
another concession then eventually maybe
he'll make a weakness then I'm in
business and of course I have to not do
this myself but the point of a5 is just
gain space and it leaves myself flexible
I might want to go here I might want to
go here I might want to go here I don't
know 95 he knows exactly how I'm
attacking him right 85 he doesn't know
yet so he plays f3 which looks pretty
safe right
so why on earth am i planning h5 do tell
me so when you have a position where
you're trying to win but you're not
really
oh don't objectively have anything you
have to ask your opponent questions you
have to force them to make decisions
with 85 I asked the question do you want
to play a four that was an easy question
I was also improving my position but
that's an easy question with h5 I'm
asking do you want to allow h4 he
thought for a long time here that
already is a win because it means to him
he's not sure whether he wants to allow
each for it or not
and in this case positionally putting
the pawn on h4 makes sense right it's on
the opposite color of the bishop's but
if I play h4 I have to be careful
because that pawn could become weak if
he ever gets an f4 put the knight on f3
who knows honestly I was maybe gonna
play with h4 but I wasn't enthusiastic
about it but my hope was not to play h4
but that he would play it the question
is why how could this move possibly be
bad that's part of it but he doesn't
really want to play f4 does he right now
white is a very solid structure right
the pawns may be on the same colors the
bishop but that's a that's a granite
pawn chain right there right if he plays
that for aha I got my weakness right I
may not win with that weakness don't get
me wrong but if I if he plays that for
I'm happy I'm very pleased because what
else can I possibly play for her g5
definitely not not not soon I play this
move so I have a threat 94 so he was
about to play 92 and then he hesitated
he was like wait a second what is the
deal
so so what do I play d5 I don't know
doesn't really threaten much believe it
or not this was my plan I know this move
looks insane but it's important that he
cannot take boom I'm sure I've mentioned
this in every lecture I've done because
I mentioned this all the time
do not forget about tactics just because
it's an Indian tactics are available all
the time but what's the problem
what if white just ignores me do I have
a threat am I gonna take what am I gonna
play next and and that you have to admit
is very annoying right this pawn white
doesn't really want that not to mention
that these pieces can't really move
right so say he plays King f2 you could
actually end up being very embarrassed
and now he has to pitch this one right
so you see how quickly things get out of
hand if you're not careful so this is
the idea that f5 and also this is an
important factor because I play at h5 in
this case it's important because if my
knight had to move back I would just
have nothing you could play King f2 or
whatever but now of course 9g for very
convenience and everything is there
whereas if I did this without h5h for
throne in this whole thing wouldn't work
tactically so h5 was kind of a trick
almost it's like it looks like I'm
trying to play h4 but really I want him
to play h4 so tactically I can play this
move but he's like ok what's the big
deal I'm just gonna play b3 no 94 no f5
because my rooks defended so what do I
do
I don't know if a four does that much if
I give him free time he's just gonna
play maybe King you know something like
king f2 also I'm not positive I want a 4
B 4 in some positions I may not want my
pawn here I don't know it's an
interesting idea though trying to get
the 8 file maybe I will say this idea
does come into play later
but hmm d5 that he can just take there's
no discovery this rooks defended by two
pieces so I could take back but this
does not accomplish anything right I
opened his rooks is what I did so not
what I'm looking for
b5 is possible I have to say the
computer in this position I remember
this very distinctly because I was like
b5 really but it's actually interesting
because I can maybe put the pawn on b4
cuz the key is that if white tries to
play d4 it allows 94
I don't know positionally this move felt
weird to me like I would have a hard
time playing b5 but it does it is an
interesting choice instead I chose to do
something slightly different
so what on earth am i doing basically
pretend it's black to move in that if
you can get another move what are you
doing yeah I think my knight is better
than whites bishop here especially after
b3 by the way more pawns on light
squares so I'm not sure I would take
immediately but I wanted him to think I
was gonna take and why can't white play
Knight d2
f5 again right and then he has to worry
about f4 all this stuff so he plays c4
so what on earth am i doing look at
these lovely pawns blocking his vision I
was feeling very pleased with myself at
this moment too pleased I'll be honest
but in my opinion regardless of how
strong the snooze with best play just
objectively it's kind of annoying to
play for white now right if you play
ninety two there's still f5 these pawns
are just in the way so it's kind of an
annoyance oh okay he plays Bishop d1
this is where I feel like he starts to
go wrong when he played Bishop d1 I saw
his plan his plan was to play F forum
Bishop f3 what do you think I thought
about this plan
to be honest I thought he just play King
f2 very solid I can't I can play I try
to play different things but I can't do
a whole lot right the fact is I can
create provoke b3c for all I want if I
can't make a breakthrough if I can't
open the position to let my pieces in
I'm still not gonna win right but what
is his idea Bishop do you want what
could he be trying I know I'm asking you
to read minds a lot today and my mind is
even worse so I apologize for that but
what do you think of f4 bishop f2 me as
a plan do you like it do you not like it
do you think it's okay so he played this
and I kept a straight face but in my
mind I was gone I want f4 I'm begging
him to play off 4 so believe it or not
my thinking on this move some of it had
to do with the fact that I did not want
to disturb him from playing f4 so I
might reject a move just because it sort
of prevents f4 this is actually not
great thinking in general but I would
just say that moves like this you do not
want to discourage when your opponent's
gonna make a mistake this is a Napoleon
thing right don't disturb them if you
see your opponent's gonna create a
weakness do not discourage it let them
go ahead I don't mean just plan nothing
move because I would look weird but do a
small improvement don't do anything
drastic let them weaken their own
position it's much harder for me to
create weaknesses of whites than it is
for white to create them on his own so
let your opponent shoot themselves in
the foot this is a large part of winning
these positions by the way because a lot
of people don't like to just sit there
most people like KF 292 holding on to
his position that's hard to play you
know a lot of people don't want to just
sit there right they want to do
something they want to create like
counter play but there are some
positions you just got a sit and if your
opponent clearly does not want to sit
that's your moment to be like ok let
them create weaknesses I'll take care of
it so he played here so I play it for
your idea
kind of annoying right because he can't
really he can't move his pawn or take
cuz this guy Hanks f4 here I go back and
this actually happens and now this hang
so he doesn't want to trade this pawn
for this pawn right that completely
kills his structure so he played Bishop
after you and now what
I still can't win with just this
weakness right he can defend it way too
many times but I've created a second
front and this is kind of the key by the
way and not any of these positions you
need to you can't just win with one
weakness you need to create somewhere
else to play defending two weaknesses at
the same time is when it becomes tricky
so what now
hmm
now I have an iPhone doesn't look like
much Annie pawn in a file but believe me
when you start out with basically
nothing this looks like Christmas this
is like all your dreams come true
objectively I wouldn't say why it's lost
or even necessarily that close but it's
it's getting dangerous now and notice
how all he did with this Bishop d1 idea
was give me an either target create more
problems for him to defend if he had
left his Bishop here brought his King
and Knight over even with the a file so
what what am I gonna do there's nothing
I can really do with that a file that's
that extraordinary by itself but because
he gave me two things to work with
now his defensive task is a lot harder
so he played ninety two so I took a limb
a little bit this is part of what
provoking weaknesses is you don't
necessarily threaten anything great but
you kind of make them annoyed now it's
like oh I have to kind of defend that
Knight that's kind of annoying so he
plays here doesn't look that amazing but
it's just kind of like you don't wanna
have to defend that night forever right
but okay I play 95 and already you can
tell that it's a little bit of an
annoying situation right but here he
really helps me by playing e5 and again
you'll find that this happens a lot part
of part of the way you win these
positions as I mentioned is you just
kind of annoy your opponent enough that
eventually they make the mistakes
themselves it's very hard to put
pressure or put pressure or slowly
increase it forever until you win
I'd say that's what the books tell you
to do but it's very rare the game ever
goes that way usually you put pressure
you put pressure and eventually they
kind of snap they just don't want to sit
anymore they don't want to kind of play
discipline chess so yeah here I mean
it's already very tough but I would say
that you know white us to try g3o it has
to somehow hold his position together
it's very difficult to do though because
I still have about 5 in the air right
because this is too many things I mean
so it's already a very difficult
situation I would say I thought he might
try be four in some positions but now I
have 96 hitting hitting this pawn and
threatening 94 you can see how all these
things add up right at first it looked
like nothing I was working with a barely
weak efore pawn now he is hold a punt
weak pawn here he is a weak pawn here he
has a knight that's hanging he has to
worry about the knight coming in
problems when you create weaknesses your
problems multiply very fast so he
decided to try e5 but now I trade and
now he has kind of a problem he'd like
to take with the night right
but what happens very simply but now
what do I take this is actually very
important so
when your position looks really good
it's easy to kind of let your guard down
I would actually say these are the most
dangerous situations when your opponent
gives you a headway you think you're
doing great right that's when you have
to actually be most cautious at least
for me I find that that's when I
sometimes make a mistake my position
gets better I built it up patiently now
my car and that's usually where bad
things happen I don't necessarily sound
like a pirate every time but that's kind
of where I make my mistake and it's easy
to just snap that pawn off but of course
whoops that would be a very sad way to
lose let me put it that way so yes but
unfortunately if I just take this pawn
b3 hangs next it's just a very very
nasty position for white so he still
should have done it he took with the
pawn which is even worse I would say so
okay I take here pawn takes rook d7
activating my rook right and again you
can see how white just has too many
weaknesses keep in mind these are all
potential weaknesses if he's not careful
he has you know his his knight is
attacked this pawn is weak you can see
how it just adds up right so imagine it
now if his pawns were back here how much
harder it would have been to win so you
got to remember this for if you're ever
defending a position like do not create
weaknesses for yourself unless you're
getting something clear after f4 he got
clear activity he started threatening me
he started attacking things that'll be
different right but because he all he
did was create a weakness his life just
became really hard I mean I don't know
if I could defend this position his
white it looks like a nightmare but okay
he played 94 and now I have a choice I
could take on e4 or take on b3 this was
a more difficult one I spent a long time
here
I'd say these decisions are hard because
both options look really good that
actually makes it harder if one option
you're not as sure about one looks
really tasty you're probably just gonna
pick that one when they're both kind of
tempting that's when things can go wrong
so what would you guys do because I can
tell you I chose what I thought was the
cleaner one and I ended up regretting my
choice almost right away Knight takes e4
is what I did
and it looked just so nice but honestly
taking um b3 I think I was afraid of
ghosts here I thought well I leave the
Knights on the board I have to worry
about Knight f6 all the time that if six
does nothing exactly but if you look at
it objectively in a knighthood game
these Ponzi ads are just weaknesses now
I mean these guys are not strengths
these guys are all potential weaknesses
c4 is a potential weakness it's not as
clean it's not as crisp because the
Knights are flying all over you have to
be careful but I think people want to
simplify too much sometimes they want to
trade too many pieces but honestly you
guys know that rook endings can be
really hard to win sometimes right so
there are times when you actually keep a
couple pieces on the board it makes your
life easier especially when your
opponent has lots of weaknesses you can
go after I thought the same would be
true in the rook endgame but the rook
endgame turned out to be very tricky so
actually taking on b3 it's a little
simpler
you just take there's no tactics there's
no nothing but it would have been a
probably a better choice I think I had
bad nightmares about east six with a
knight here and I remember some game I
played 50 years ago where that was
annoying I don't know I can't tell you
exactly but sometimes keeping material
on the board can actually help you win
rather than making it harder so I took
rook d3 so I still win a pawn it's not
like I don't want a pawn but life
becomes kind of annoying plays King g2
so yeah II six might have annoyed me a
little bit but I think this was the idea
I underestimated I assume that his pawns
would actually be kind of weak but this
is actually really annoying because
these pawns technically this is weak
right but how am I going to take
advantage his King defends both pawns
the fact that these pawns are split is
not that meaningful and I can tell you
guys that when you get to a reduced rook
endgame it's very hard to win usually
there just isn't much material rooks are
really nasty at giving checks I wasn't
sure I could win this so I was kind of
happy he didn't go for e6 he played rook
d4 which looks like a better a really
nice try also but it's not as clear he
so this was kind of a difficult moment
for me I thought that after rook c3
white had a draw but I was mistaken so
my I guess I have a two-part question
here first find what I thought was a
draw and then find what I missed because
this was my plan I should tell you from
when I traded when I took on e4 I saw to
this position and I thought I was
winning but then I saw an idea for him I
was not happy about and yes I do have a
lots of feelings
yeah I was literally I missed this move
initially I thought he could he just had
to play route d7 but now I take and this
pawn looks kind of nasty but I don't
know I didn't think it was the worst
thing in the world there are some
positions I could play here but now
there's a seven so I have to be a little
careful so one trick I think I could
play here was play this check so the
trick is that if he goes up now I go
here and if e7 I go here I just win and
the point of King f6 by the way this is
a very common trick so if you haven't
seen this rockin name trick when the
pawns pin you go here the trick is that
you provoke the pawn to take and then
you go back and you see how this pawn is
just nothing that's kind of the trick
and here I push this pawn to connected
pawns should be fairly easy but now he
can play King f1 and now I can't do that
however I've tricked him because of this
check now his King has to be here so I
can't play king of King up 6 coz of e7
you guys see that right so here maybe I
even just go here allow rook takes and
King here but the problem is this B pawn
is super fast and because it's Kings
here it's even quicker to win his rook
right so sometimes these little check
moves and rook and games can make a big
difference because if I checked him in
this position he would just go King g3
right no problem but because I checked
him when he couldn't go to g3
for tactical reasons he had to go to a
bad square so actually didn't remember
all this but I did I didn't calculate
this during the game I I was using my
time for something but I did miss e6
which is not a good move to miss guys
don't miss he 6 but I do have a solution
actually I thought that this had to be
just a draw but it's not
and it should it's really it's one of
those things that's kind of obvious when
you see it but for some reason when I
was calculating it didn't occur to me so
my move here is kind of forced right
he's gonna play I mean well II seven is
already a winning threat because the
Brooke III rookie for right so I can't
allow he's seven so I don't have so many
moves right what am I gonna do if King
f6 he just takes I didn't gain anything
there king outfeed I don't know maybe
even takes there remember I'm not even
threatening a pawn here I thought I had
to take which I do but I thought this
had to be a draw because I thought these
pawns trade I'm not gonna win this three
versus two with split pawns no chance
but I actually do not have to trade
these pawns here and here I made a very
common mistake I would say even GM's
make this mistake a lot which is that we
have a conceptual thing we've seen a
zillion rook in games we've seen that
these pawns always get traded what
happens is this pawn runs this rook runs
this pawn runs the rook goes behind
take-take-take everyone's happy and you
don't win because you trade these pawns
right but when you see this sometimes it
forces you to be lazy
if I weren't lazy what would I have seen
I know it's hard to imagine a world in
which I'm not lazy but we're gonna try F
of King e6 um it's similar I mean I
think the better move order is just King
e5 just immediately go after the pawn if
ii 5 you maybe have to worry about rook
check sometimes I don't know you're may
what might work too but I think kini 5
is even easier and you just go over and
for some reason I didn't see this I
didn't see wait a second I just go over
and take this pawn my Kings move more
active than white so basically I guess
the lesson here is just don't stop when
you're calculating until the very end
and don't rely on your assumptions just
because I had seen these pawns trade
before doesn't mean that this position
is not different
so it's a mistake which I mean a lot of
players make a lot and it's so rooks III
would have been slightly more accurate I
played King f8 not a horrible move but
it's very difficult to win now
so rook d7 he played c5 b6
King g3 so here I calculate a long time
of course here I have to be careful
because if I allow the King in who knows
bad things can happen
so I played rugby for yeah so this was a
tricky moment I was worried about king
f4 during the game and I wasn't sure I
could do much here but I can take and b5
and it's very important that King f6
doesn't work because of rook F floor
check but he plays f4 and now what
very nice stops out five in its tracks
right because the rook takes e5 still
can't go here
so Luke takes pawn
yep
and I think this was the concept I
missed if B 3 I might lose you have to
be very careful when this King gets in I
can do this
and it's kind of cool because it's me
I'm threatening me if f6 King h7 it's
still mate and what happens if this and
this is surely what I missed
that would have been a cool way to win
but I did not see this during the game
so I was very worried but he played here
I took and this was the key moment you
have to figure out how to win here
because there are so many times you get
this position but you just can't win so
I calculated a long time finally decided
on this move so yeah I thought you might
try King f4 but here if e6 I was ff6
it's kind of important to keep his King
out and if here I can play King e7 and I
couldn't find a way for white to draw
but it was still probably a better try
he played rook d7 I played C 4 C 3 C 2
but the question is how on earth am I
gonna win
he plays check so guys how do you win
his black right but let's let me just
show you white please check but I had to
be very careful what I did this because
if you're not accurate you can end up
losing I've seen these real kind games
lost before I'm sure I've done it myself
but I play King d5 and then where's the
King go
if I go to c5 I have to watch out for
the rook d2 defense right because now if
I move the rook and my pawn can advance
so here I can't do anything so yes
c4 an idea now is if black tries to go
up my king is too close so I play king
c3 his rook goes here my rook goes here
and I'm too fast
so King c4 is important so he plays east
six if you play is check how does this
work
have to be a little careful maybe this
works I mean probably this will win yeah
it wins because you can do everything
with check because if it takes Queen
Queen check yeah I wasn't as sure about
this one my plan just so you know was
actually just too good to be five
because now there's no roof d2 right so
he asked him who's rook somewhere and
then I push and now he has to give up a
rook right so he tried e six and rook
check so now what
down
we trade I bring my came back and he
resigned here but basically the idea is
that with the King this close it's very
simple
you just bring the king every move use
the rook it's quite simple to it but the
basic idea is that the rook endgame
became very complicated right this was a
win but it was really a win by one tempo
so you can see how close the rook
endgame is if I had kept the Knights on
the board I probably would have won more
comfortably so the temptation to
simplify often has to be really resisted
but I could say if there's any strategic
concept this whole game that you guys
should take away it's that be careful
when you simplify at the beginning of
the game he's simplified and what
happens his advantage just went up in
smoke
right because his advantage was based on
that the better were lots of pieces and
he had a space advantage so all the
traits and then towards the end I was
the one who traded incorrectly so there
are times when you got to keep pieces on
the board you got to keep their things
also I take note of his idea of Bishop
d1 f4 because this is a common type of
mistake again you'll see it up to 2300
level more than say 2500 level when they
get to that level they stop doing it
a lot more and the reason is because we
just have this experience of we've been
hurt so many times when we create
weaknesses so do not create weaknesses
you do not have to create especially if
you're not really doing anything with
those moves and I guess the other one is
just be patient you know imagine like
okay this is a 2300 imagine you're
playing a 2,000 or an 1800 how many
mistakes are they gonna make in a
position like that probably a lot more
right so if you stay patient you keep
improving your position you keep asking
them questions moves like h 585 keeping
the tension you'll often provoke
mistakes in a position they shouldn't
necessarily lose so you have to show
patience you have to be accurate when
you know that the position becomes more
concrete you have to calculate
variations but essentially be patient
wait for them to create the weaknesses
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]